so
[Music]
you picked the wrong day too huh the
faculty retreat doesn't start till
tomorrow
it went in your mouth in and right
straight in oh
um
that is good oh
wow we say uh one more yeah
jack
this thing between us i
i can't
deny it anymore
i uh
i don't know what you mean
i must have you
[Music]
the upper peninsula winds whipped
against the windows and the fire roared
as the two men wondered
would this be the night their forbidden
passions became reality
durbin inhaled jack's hot twizzler
breath moaning quietly as he inched
closer to his supple lips
durbin wouldn't do that his quiet
reluctance is part of his character and
the twizzler takes us out of it i'm
experimenting what are you guys doing
nothing we're shipping nothing i'm an
in-principal dervin
so you write romance and awful stories
about them cause that'd be funny it's
about pairing people in power
it's essentially fan fiction but we
write them about the teachers can i play
you can't just play there's a lot of
world building involved
listen
blackjack griffin couldn't remember the
last time he'd had a bath
couldn't remember what it felt like to
have a naked body pressed against his
that was all about to change
or so he thought
[Music]
whiskey there's only one rule in the old
west talk straight shoot straight walk
crooked
i thought you were dead
how many times i got to kill you
principal durbin said well it doesn't
seem like he'd go by that there i don't
know his first name
i'm sorry i shot you
jerry
i felt bad for that
prostitute i get it i was acting funny
because my horse thieving wife had gone
and got herself hanged
and i didn't have no one to
touch
i reckon everyone needs the warmth of
someone else's body sometimes
or else
or else they die
blackjack don't
oh
now you're shy
durbin found himself taking refuge in
his embrace
hiding in its comfort
okay i i get it let me try
mr griffin knew exactly what he was
doing when he pulled the brown cardigan
out of the drawer he was the kind of man
who hid what was broken in himself under
three days of stubble and a wrinkled
shirt like these things would make his
pain into a joke make him into someone
who didn't feel pain at all
but principal durbin wore his pain on
the outside in a starch color and a belt
that matches shoes the kind of pain that
begs to be looked at caressed
they were the same in a way men like
that
they reach a point where there's nothing
left to talk about
all you have is a heart beating so loud
and so fast you wonder if everyone can
hear it and you wonder if just maybe
what's broken in him might make a home
for what's broken in you
wonder if the man across from you is
thinking about pulling you down on the
sturdy wooden desk between you
she's good
all right everybody
shush it
i got tricked last night yeah i want
everybody to line up and uh take a bite
of this
tell me if you think they were correct
in calling this mild because i think
it's too hot
it's too hot
faculty and students i have just been
informed by the toledo weather
federation we are officially in a
tornado watch it's coming it's coming
it's coming i need all teachers to take
their students to the gym auditorium or
a hallway
with no windows we are officially on
lockdown
it's definitely too spicy mr griffin
you